we were losing and i was battling with a
lot of you know old habits that i was
doing like last year and my rookie year
i was able to get away with grabbing
somebody's face mass or you know talking
smack and the ref not hearing me but you
know it's a lot of eyes on me now and i
didn't realize that yeah you know i got
ejected out of the green bay game and i
was like alright dk you got to chill now
[Music]
well hello
how are you doing
what is that
yeah what's this this new shoe this new
accessory yeah uh that's a little boot
uh i had a little booboo during the
season but got everything cleaned up
okay so you know i've got to figure out
timeline here right
when did you get the surgery uh right
after the season okay
and how are you feeling now what's the
rehab looking like um well i just
started walking uh on it a couple days
ago uh rehab's gonna be like another
month before i'm full go yeah yeah
i am i'll have to say i'm amazed that
nobody knew that you did this i mean i
kept i kept it under arrest yeah
absolutely even i said uh did you go to
radio how have i not seen any news blurb
about the fact that dj metcalf is in a
boot so were you intentionally kind of
trying to stay in and not making news or
i mean it just happened that way yeah
just was trying to detach from football
and detox them all the season and all of
that
just so happened that way so this injury
was something that you were dealing with
throughout the season yeah how much did
it affect you was just a thing that you
were really focusing on when you weren't
on the field what was that looking like
um i don't think it affected me that
much um i i missed like uh a practice
day a week um you know when i found out
um you know what happened to my foot but
yeah it really didn't affect me that
much it's crazy the way you all like
play through these big injuries like we
had micah on the show a couple days ago
and he's like oh actually i was hurt
the entire season and nobody really knew
that i was dealing with this but he said
his was super
super painful so luckily
yeah okay cause i remember in the press
conference somebody asked you what
you're gonna do with the foot and you
said you and pete were gonna discuss it
but i feel like at that point you
probably already knew what was going on
but
i'm like he's lying up there
no it's not good you should do whatever
makes you feel the most comfortable but
it's good to see you too boot and all um
i always have wanted to ask you this
question because i think about it
whenever i see you i think for a lot of
people they were introduced to you at
first with the photo where everybody was
like looking at the abs and the muscles
and all these things and it was
everywhere like it was talked about so
much that it was like synonymous with
that calf
when you are like on display in that way
do you feel uncomfortable very i don't
like my my body being out there like
that um you know it's just just
something i'm not comfortable with um
you know myself yeah um i'm i'm working
on it but yeah
do you feel like objectified almost
i wouldn't say that i just feel like um
i i'm known as a label now so every time
when somebody sees me i'm either a
workout warrior or you know the guy with
the abs with or the guy with all the
memes uh you know about you know family
stuff or
you know what not but you know i want to
be i don't want to be known as that i
want to be known as you know caitlin
metcalf you know the football player you
know who also did good in the community
and you know just did what he wanted to
do yeah
that's a thing that's so interesting
about social media now and really just
like society in general is
it's so easy to become one thing right
and then so now you're like trying to
figure out how can you get out of just
being known as as that one thing exactly
i mean how do you feel like you do that
um i mean i'm it's kind of working
backwards now because you know the world
already views me as one way and then i
got to work against that and you know i
got to show my other interests like hook
and kids prison fellowship so you know
i would say the nfl does a pretty good
job of that with you know my claws my
cleats and you know other things of that
nature but i'm really working backwards
and just trying to create my own brand
instead of you know the brand the world
put on me yeah but also being like all
right i got to keep these apps
i need everyone to know that i i do
still have uh to have all the muscles
okay wait so you said cooking
you're a chef a little bit yeah what's
your go-to dish uh alfredo
okay
like how often are you cooking oh no i'm
not cooking that much though okay yeah
but it is something you're interested in
yeah it's something that um you know i
went to school for hospitality
management so
restaurants and hotels is something that
that is interesting uh to me yeah okay
favorite food to eat
food
everything yeah i'm low-key like i love
food all of it yeah like are you a
person who will try everything yes i
definitely would try like i tried caviar
last night for the first time thoughts
one good wasn't it no my last time
trying it for sure you did it alone or
did it like on a cracker
i was at a dinner so i was basically
forced to everybody was at the table
like
so you're going to try to catch your i'm
like yeah i might as well yeah you must
have been at some elite dinner i don't
go to dinner as a read caveat you used
to focus so
oh that is so funny okay wait so you
said culinary kids tell me what you love
about kids um well i'm the oldest of six
so i got five younger siblings so i mean
i love kids basically you know raised my
younger siblings uh you know just me and
my mom while my dad was at work but uh
kids is something that just strikes an
interest in me how pure they are and you
know they're always happy and smiling
and joyful and they're the most honest
creatures right exactly yeah even when
you don't want them to be so
what's like the funniest thing a kid has
said to you about yourself
my brothers call me ugly all the time so
they look just like me so i could just
say it right back to them but no they
just like like my baby cousin uh she's
like she's two
and like we just teach her little slang
words like for show or oh you gang for
real so like just here i'll say that
it's just funny i love that okay the
third thing you said was prison
fellowship right tell me about that um
well prison fellowship is just like a
charity that i support uh you know
during the season with my calls my
cleats um and anytime i have
you know a platform or is
anytime i'm brought across it i try to
just bring awareness to it i was sitting
in church one day and the word was about
um you know prisoners and how they don't
have you know the same you know
advantage that we have of getting the
word of god so it was just something
that struck an interesting interest with
me and you know just tried to run with
it from there yeah i mean when you talk
about like being pigeonholed into one
thing i think too often people do that
with anybody who has been incarcerated
for any moment and it's so hard to like
leave that this happen to you like move
forward so i think that's that's really
important there's a really good
i think it's on hbo um but it's a dock
it's called it's a hard truth ain't it
and the prisoners like create their own
documentary about their lives and they
got there and what it's really good
though yeah giving them prisoners a
voice so yeah yeah absolutely and i
thought that was that was nice because
then they got really into filmmaking
right like understanding how to tell a
story especially when it's like their
story so
if you're ever on a flight you need
something to watch watch that but see
he's more than just the uh the viral
picture
of the abs and the muscles you see right
there um but okay so a couple years
under your belt in the league
when you were you know doing your
pre-draft process something that always
sticks out to me you said you haven't
seen a dk in the nfl yet
tell me what you meant by that um well
i'm gonna do stuff my way whether it's
you know how i play or how i act off the
field or even on the field like i'm just
gonna do stuff my way and i don't think
people you know the league hasn't seen
somebody who's really just done that and
just stuck you know to what he's done
and
i think i'm i'm doing it yeah when you
think about all the wide receivers out
there right now and i think it changes
every year we always have these
conversations of like who does everybody
like right now who's the best right now
i'm not asking you to do that but when
you look at the past season and you
think of the tiers of wide receivers
where do you place yourself
i'm always going to place myself at the
top but you know that's that's personal
preference yeah i know everybody has
their own list everybody has their own
personal preferences you know from
either where you grew up or if you're a
fan of that person or whatnot
i'm just going to continue to be me and
if you like me you like me if you don't
give yourself a grade last season
i'm going to give myself a b
minus b
in that area yeah y b minus um well i
didn't have the the numbers that i
wanted to and we had a losing season so
it was just a lot of stuff that was
piling up on top of each other
what was the goal you wanted to hit um
of course everybody once said a thousand
yards um you were close yeah i know yeah
30
wasn't where it available to be so
everything was just like in a in a world
like aol so i wasn't succeeding the team
was wasn't succeeding so it was just
really a lot of stuff how do you handle
losing
i don't like it i don't like losing at
all because you know when you win and
you can you get relaxed and you can have
fun with stuff but you know when you're
losing it's always all right what do we
do wrong so let's over compensate for
this one thing and then you get relaxed
in another area so when you win it feels
like you can just free flow and just
play
yeah like
obviously losing is bad because it's for
your record but i think people
underestimate how losing makes you play
really tight right and then that has the
effect of more losing because you're not
playing the way that that you're meant
to be what's like that mental battle
with losing and adjusting well my coach
says is never as good as it seems it's
never as bad as it seems so you know you
always got to watch the film and go back
and fix your mistakes so you all you can
never be just too hard on yourself when
you know you're watching film or you're
going through a loss because you know
it's like he said it's never as bad as
it seems so yeah that's something i try
to work on and not try to you know get
into that mental battle with myself like
oh do this next time or do this next
time just you know just calm down and
just be yourself and chill yeah most
people would see your stat line and say
oh i'd love to have a season like that
yeah that's
me yeah i look at myself and i know what
i'm capable of so yeah that's the only
reason i'm i'm lowkey hot what are you
ultimately capable of um i don't know
man we're gonna see i'm trying to break
record so okay that's what i believe i'm
capable of breaking a lot of records
specific record that comes to mind um i
mean everybody wants the receiving yards
record you know randy moss and tom brady
they got like 23 touchdowns in a year so
yeah that's gonna be that's gonna be
real tough but uh the receiving yards
record is something that i really have
my own
now i know in a lot of ways this season
was growth you know for a lot of people
and there was a period where you kind of
had three outbursts season in that time
what was going on um we were losing and
i was battling with a lot of
you know old habits that i was doing
like last year and my rookie year i was
able to get away with grabbing
somebody's face mask or you know talking
smack and the ref not hearing me but you
know it's a lot of eyes on me now and i
didn't realize that
so you know i got ejected out of the
green bay game and i was like alright dk
you got to chill now
that was like kind of the moment you
said i need to
figure it out yeah so this happens you
go home tell me the conversation you're
having with yourself right in order to
get out of that so on the on the plane
um i'm sitting with uh bobby wagner and
uh yeah and uh he was talking to me
because he was when i got ejected he was
the one that came up and was like dk you
got to chill i'm like bro get out of my
face i'm come down by myself it was like
no thing about your future like because
uh you know he's somebody that i respect
and i'll listen to and once he said that
like i snapped out of it and then he
talked to me on the plane it was like
look you're not the same dk you're not a
rookie no more you're not a second-year
player like you're a superstar so start
acting like one people always try to get
under your skin so just be above it and
you know having talks with him you know
my brother they just calmed me down and
just made me realize like i'm above all
that stuff yeah but i mean how hard is
it to break old habits
i mean i'm still battling with a lot of
stuff um you know but i mean it's hard
um i'm going through a lot of therapy
and you know mental uh you know help uh
you know with my coaches and everything
so um i mean it's gonna be easier next
season
yeah so when you say therapy you mean
actual therapy like going to see a
therapist right yes okay you know we're
we're big therapy advocates on the show
we talk about it a lot how has it helped
you um well i started going in may so it
probably didn't look like it during the
season but i was going to therapy but
it's a journey right yeah yeah wrong one
built in today so that's probably you
could walk but um i mean it helped me a
lot just with my viewpoint of life and
you know how i carry myself and you know
just just
everything in general like i see life
and football differently like i cherish
it more
cherish relationships more
um i don't get as angry anymore because
you know i'm above it all yeah
so for therapy do you find yourself
talking more about football more about
life
both
the past couple of sessions have been
more about football because you know i'm
tired of watching teams playing on
sunday and i'm not suiting up so
a lot of it has been about football but
a lot of it is about life as well yeah
are you getting good like coping
mechanisms and figuring out what to do
to make yourself yeah i started
meditating so
nice i
i was
not a meditator at all like i would talk
bad about it yeah now
look at me i'm i'm a mediterranean yeah
and it helps because i think people
hear meditation and they think it means
you're like sitting and you're like
yes but it's not it's really just like
checking in with yourself exactly yes
you do it every day uh no probably once
a week though whenever i i feel myself
my blood pressure rising i'll just take
a step back and just chill play a little
music yeah just think about stuff has
there been a time during the season when
you're playing that you almost had to
like stop and do that oh yes during the
season yes yeah no i mean like in a game
in a game yeah yeah tell me it tell me
the last game of the season yeah so i
knew i had to i knew my goal uh going
into the season i've been going to the
last game at like 30 or 40 something
yards to get
um and i knew you know i wasn't going to
get it so it was like 12 minutes left
and we were running the ball running the
ball and i'm like
you know what this is a team game
are we winning let me just chill out
this is not about me it's yeah it's not
about me that's all i had to tell myself
so yeah we won the game you know
finished the season i was strong so that
was that was a positive
no i love hearing that because probably
before you learn to check in with
yourself and ask yourself those
questions
if that happened to you a year ago you
maybe would have lashed out
you know what i mean or been on that bus
mad and all these things so see guys
therapy teaches you
amazing amazing things um okay so when
you think about that last season now
that we you know we have coping
mechanisms and we're figuring everything
out i think i read that you are not
going to watch the super bowl right yeah
because you're going to watch euphoria
correct okay
you're going to catch up on euphoria
i've only seen the first two episodes of
this season yeah me too i'm on like
episode three like 40 minutes into the
third episode yeah so you're trying to
like avoid twitter because you know
they're talking about it exactly yeah if
i see something like oh or a little mean
they have like memes
of people now and i'm like yeah let me
go ahead and scroll past that because i
don't want no hints or anything yeah
it's such a good show although sometimes
i'm like
was my high school just not that cool i
was about to say is that a bit much
was i under a rock or something but no
yeah it's like bits and pieces of it i'm
like okay yes this specific thing
happened at my school
but it wasn't happening with like this
this this and just like a whole my high
school experience scale was like a three
compared to euphoria yeah and remind me
where you and like went to high school
oxford okay
okay speaking of i saw you were with eli
yes last night yes what's eli like he
seems very funny and i hear he's like
i didn't know he was gonna put that
picture out like that i was just going
to send it to my dad because they played
together but yeah i got on twitter and i
seen like he was like oh what if i would
have wore the same outfit as big cam
like bro come on you have to talk about
my fit like that just give me a
compliment in person if we can move on
but yeah i think you responded to it you
were like oh whoa you wouldn't look that
crazy yeah
oh that is so funny okay so i want to
get into a lot of just your skill as a
player and there's a bunch of talented
players right in league devo samuel
you two are two people that people
discuss a lot
tell me some things that debo can do
that you can't and things that you do
that depot can't um i'm not gonna say
can't but i would rather not line up in
the backfield at running back that's
something i'm not no i'm six-fold
i'm not about to line up in the
backfield yeah debo is a very versatile
player to where he could line up in the
backfield he can go out to receive he
can go on the slide he can return punts
and kicks like he's a very
versatile player to where the 49ers did
a very good job of using them you know
at the end of the season or when they
did have him healthy so uh i would say
he has a lot of tools in his
in his uh pocket okay and the opposite
that's something that you do that you
don't see him do
i really don't i don't like doing this
yeah i don't like talking about other
players yeah in a negative way so i'm
gonna just say um i'm very fast i'm
fascinated yeah you are very fast i
think that's one thing that we all know
and that's not a slight to devo
you are a very very fast person is
olympics something that is like a goal
of yours yeah for sure like a legitimate
one not just like i want to go out there
and try no i'm not just running just
around yeah i can do that on the track
somewhere yeah trying to try and go to
the olympics okay what's that process
like are you
starting that because i mean you know
that's a hole yes i'm in a boot right
now so i can't i can't do too much but
uh next year um i'm gonna start back
training for it every off season
training for the 100 meter or 60 meter
whichever one i decide to do yeah um and
then in 2024 you'll see me again
that is so cool like it has to happen
right oh yeah for sure it's gonna happen
yeah okay i love the confidence you see
the confidence um i know you said that
you're not gonna watch the game on
sunday but somebody who's going to be in
that game is jalen ramsey
what is it like matching up with jalen
um
it's always a battle i'll say that
going against their defense is always a
battle because yeah you got a lot of
people to worry about over there so i
would say it's gonna be a fun game just
to you know
hear about the matchup between you know
him and chase or t and jamal i mean uh
jaylen and you know their whole defense
uh you know see if
their o-line can block their d-line so i
think it's just going to be a good game
all around yeah to you like what makes a
good corner
confidence okay yeah so anybody who
could get caught on and then come back
the next play and still have the same
swag or still have the same confidence i
think that's a dangerous attribute
you know as a corner you know everything
else is i can work around yeah i can
work around somebody being fast or
strong or no quick feet i can work
around all this stuff but
for corner has confidence is not scared
to get beat then you know that's when
you got a problem yeah like if a
corner if they believe they can outlast
you exactly yeah yeah like that's the
real that's the real issue do you have
like tell me your two favorite matchups
like you like going against these two
quarters um i would say jalen number one
number two
oh lattimore he was yeah lattimore was a
good matchup for me yeah
oh yeah i remember that that was a good
one it was an eventful game
but it was a good matchup although as a
falcons man i don't like the saints so
you gotta you gotta best lotta more in
that match up if only if only for me i
remember reading you saying
like you said i you were at ole miss you
said i don't really watch film i just go
out there and play how have your film
habits changed oh he's saying he's
drastically yeah yeah now that you're in
that yeah okay tell me walk me through
what a film session with you looks like
what you're looking for from yourself
and from your opponent you're trying to
give away all my tips now
give me the surface okay uh yeah so when
i'm watching a db i'll uh watch them
probably i'll start watching film on
friday
i can't watch film during the week
because our dbs they still trying to
play on sundays and they're not going to
be the dbm going again so
i'm watching them i work i watch to see
us press man technique first all right
is he come to balance or he's going to
step with his inside foot if then i
watch see if he throws hands if he
doesn't then no that's all i watch for
because anybody off uh
you know playing off coverage on me i
think i'm gonna eat up that ground and
then they're gonna start panicking so
yeah i mainly watch that press technique
okay so you're all in on the film now
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah you're like the
same people
too
were you almost like surprised at like
how much it is like very beneficial like
if you're watching the film ole miss it
probably would have been even crazier
exactly yes you know and i see how much
film rush watching this
night and day yeah yeah tell me about
his work ethic because that's all i hear
is that he is the hardest working guy in
the league he is a robot yeah he comes
in season like all right getting waking
up at six getting your body taken care
of watching film coming to the facility
staying till it's like seven eight
o'clock at night talking to the coaches
working on his crab like he's all in on
all of that yeah or like being injured
and not playing but literally going
through all the motions yes
yeah it's wild
how do you build chemistry with a
quarterback because i think that's
another thing people underestimate about
this league is like even when you're not
on the field you're working towards
being better like so much of it is
having that synergy so how are you able
to do that i think work russ seemed my
work ethic and you know how bad i wanted
to be great and he wanted he wants me to
be great just as bad as i want to be
great so uh he's seen that and he just
brought me along with him like he would
start texting me and bobby would text me
and like we would work out um you know
me i'd go stay with russ during the
off-season at his career so it's just
like a lot of little stuff that he
picked up on that you know we're chasing
the same goal and i need him he needs me
so we're just working together and i
know you guys have a really close
relationship and he's some money i'm
sure it gives you a lot of words of
wisdom what's the most valuable thing um
that he has said to you um the most
valuable thing i would say my first time
meeting russ ever um was in the locker
room he sat me down beside him
tried to little boy me i wasn't trying
to i wouldn't have it but uh he was just
telling me like all right so you got a
lot of friends now
you know if you want to be great you
want to be successful in this world you
know you can't bring everybody with you
they're either going to grow with you or
grow apart from you so don't be
surprised when people start growing
apart from you and
he was right yeah and that and that
stuck with you yeah
i love the bond between you know
quarterbacks and their receivers and i
know receivers love their guys i'm sure
you saw on the internet when there was a
big fuss because ryan clark was talking
about russell wilson and not being a guy
that can get you to a super bowl that he
shouldn't be in those conversations is
the best or you know whatever ryan said
what was your reaction to seeing all of
that
i didn't even see it oh okay it was the
whole thing i'm so i'm so oblivious to a
lot of stuff going on sometimes so i i
did not pay attention but yeah now that
i'm hearing it now i mean russ has
already won a super bowl taking a team
to it twice so i mean his resume speaks
for himself so yeah yeah is that does it
ever bother you if you feel like
somebody is like doubting your
quarterback uh no cause i know the type
of person he is he's gonna
hear it
use it as fuel and you know push to the
side like he's working he's probably
working out now yeah and talking to
himself like all right they said this he
was already a fourth round draft pick so
i mean he has a huge chip on his
shoulder i'm not worried about you know
anything getting to him yeah absolutely
i think i read
when you were with him in the off-season
you swam i knew that
he taught me how to swim and swam and
swimming was not something you were
doing before can you walk me through
that see i almost drowned when i was
little and it like traumatized me to
where if water gets like right here my
heart starts beating
fast as heck so i'm like all right
he was like um we're going to mexico
you're chilling with me you know we're
going to go to the pool
i said the pool how deep is it he said
out four feet you could stand up and i
was like all right bet
we get to the pool it's a six foot in or
a seven foot in or something like that
he was like oh i forgot about that i was
like yeah i bet you did he was like all
right jump in i'm like bro i'll put my
feet in i'm not jumping in the water he
was like all right just trust me i got
you
first day all i did was stand in the
water
second day he got me holding my breath
underwater taught me how to breathe and
relax and then the third day i was
pushing off the wall swimming a little
bit
you know he taught me how to how to swim
a little bit he got my confidence up
i'll give him his props yeah okay so now
if you would go to the pool you're a bit
more comfortable
yeah okay but
in the facility i'll swim by myself and
no supervision so yeah that's good i
mean so much of that is trust right yeah
for sure yeah yeah i don't i don't trust
him like that still but you know he he
helped me a lot with swimming so yeah
yeah i mean what do you think what was
it about russ's presence
that made you you know have the
confidence to do it um it was russ and
he wasn't gonna let me just leave
without
him at least trying to attempt to teach
me how to swim yeah so i i was like
he's going to talk about me if i don't
do it
he's going to have a story to say if i
don't do it so i was like i might as
well just do it yeah
is like the water or you know being deep
in the water something you'd say is a
fear of yours that's for sure yeah yeah
swimming is very fun but i understand
that see i'm getting scared talking
about it really
you're like where are we at are we still
on land okay so you guys very clearly
have like a strong relationship a good
bond that kind of
second half of the season when he came
back
it felt like you guys are missing
sometimes right what do you attribute
that to um i really don't attribute it
to just one thing you know solely i
think you know it's a you know new oc
and you know o-line was getting changed
out a lot um you know russ was getting
back from his finger
i was dealing with my foot tyler was in
and out because of covet and everything
so it was just a lot of different
variables just thrown no at a set in one
year
like we played a game on tuesday
come on
a tuesday game yeah yeah like it was
just a lot of different stuff just being
thrown at us you know all year but you
know we fought through it you know the
best they would the best that we could
um
and next year you know we're gonna be
fighting back yeah i think sometimes
everybody looks for these very like
dramatic answers as to why
some people just like maybe weren't
hitting on all cylinders but a lot of
the time it is as simple as that like
it's a lot of different things that were
playing a role and it just wasn't
working we figured it out and that's
kind of the game of football in general
um you were asked about your future with
the seahawks and you said i'm not trying
to leave does that still hold true yes
i'm not trying to why would i want to
leave yeah and go to a new place now
mm-hmm yeah why do you like it why do
you want to stay um it was the first
place they drafted me so they took a
chance on me when you know they passed
me up one time and then i was like all
right we can't do it twice and every
other team passed me up twice so yeah
yeah they hold a special place in my
heart
where are we at this moment with
negotiations figuring it out how are we
feeling oh they still got to play the
super bowl still got to do that yeah
another combine draft so you know
whenever they decide and my agent
decides to talk and i'll just be kick
back my feet up yeah
and i know in that press conference you
know someone was talking to you about
how this contract does have the
potential to really like set some
precedent you know for wide receivers do
you feel that kind of going into it i
haven't heard anything so no yeah you're
like i'm just killing them i'm so
oblivious to a lot of stuff where i
don't i don't like talking about
football for like a couple months i'm
not doing it are you like an unplugged
person yes i will detach completely
really yes and that starts like right
after the super bowl yeah no right after
the season oh yeah
i'm not like listening to any of the
things and why do you do that just to
keep your sanity yes and i was doing it
for six months you know nine to five
every day so
i was just trying to get away from it
completely
okay so well first off before i even
forget i saw bobby wagner yesterday at
the tonal event and i told him i was
interviewing you and he said why have
you not asked me to do the interview you
have to shout me out with the interview
so shout out to bobby wagner
no he's great is he somebody that you
look too yeah yeah he's just like so
chill and smart and even killed and like
i just feel like he has so much wisdom
yes you know what i mean i don't know if
people like understand that about but
he's also like super business savvy he's
just like a great person
who outside of your team do you look to
for mentorship um
i'm around them all the time yeah so
either
bobby i would go to my brother
my pops my mom
or my therapist those are pretty much
the people i really talk to about you
know a lot of stuff okay well i'd have
to say you're gonna have to talk to
somebody about this take that you
tweeted which one
calamari
look and ranch look don't don't get me
started i told you i like food
no i'm passionate about this or not
now in calamari
you're gonna have to sell me on it why
why not you gonna do marinara marinara
belongs on spaghetti
not calamari
you got to have ranch with calamari or
some aioli sauce well you can't just eat
alien ranch aren't this like those are
two different things right but you can't
have like they brought out a plate of
calamari with marinara sauce
and just the calamari
as it should be garnished with cilantro
on there nothing like and then i tasted
when it just tastes bad like i was
i was looking forward to the ranch not
gonna lie
so how did the ranch combo even like
happen like red lobster so
growing up in the south
we would go up i don't see a ranch you
we would go to red lobster olive garden
you know at the church
um order the calamari you know they got
the little blue bowl things
you have a side of marinara and a side
of ranch i'm so used to dipping it in a
ranch
i'm tasting the ranch now
i was disappointed and heartbroken when
i ordered calamari and i didn't see any
ranch
i was
very disappointed
and i thought that was the first time
that's ever happened to me ever really
yes okay i grew up in georgia i don't
ever remember there being ranch next to
that calamari red lobster
we need to take a poll somewhere yeah
well first off show of hands does anyone
in here do ranch with calamari
stop it
what
no no this was like a very polarizing
tweet one of the most polarizing of all
time i can't believe how many people
just
obliviously like no ranch calamari that
doesn't go
yeah because it it doesn't
it does you guys have done it but do you
like it
not a thing i like how assertive is yeah
yeah he's like absolutely exactly yeah
that's how i feel he's he's absolutely
backing you up oh my gosh no i never did
that and you know after church it was
also like did y'all have um ryan's or
golden corral like you did the buffet
yeah but you go there during the week
that's tuesday yeah it's like half price
uh 7.99 yeah well but also
for me growing up
like i thought red lobster was the
fanciest coolest place ever me too like
when they said what do you want to go
for your birthday i'd say we're lobster
they're like i'm gonna go to wrong
lobster sure but i think it's like fine
dining right i would get the ultimate
feast which had everything in it was
like a lobster tail fried shrimp shrimp
scampi crab legs skin a little bit
everything get those biscuits
well the draft process really opened my
eyes
first first restaurant i went to was uh
my financial advisors took me to nobu
different
red lobster look like a mcdonald's now
that's what i've been missing but the
portions be small so i gotta i gotta
load up but that's how it goes did you
go to nobu malibu yes
see that's also the environment there
like you have the water and it's so
pretty what'd you do like yellow tail
you have to see he ordered i i went hip
to the menu so i just yeah handle all
this stuff but they got some good tacos
yeah they're tiny yes that's right a
little bite size oh i live at nobu in
new york because you know there's two in
new york and there's one like not far
from me so i go there all the time nobu
is like the absolute best but yeah look
at you now you eating caviar at super
bowl week oh yeah going to nobu
also okay i i'm happy you're here
because i always ask odell about this
these
tell me the process
all right so you gotta go to a dentist
right okay they have to take impressions
then they have to send them off to a lab
these are the middle four actually
veneers
so they have to put the diamond in the
tooth and then like mold it and i don't
know how a tooth works something near
works yeah but then i had like temps and
then like where the temps for like two
weeks took him out and he put these in
like these are just veneers yeah yeah
but it's like to get them out would be
like a whole thing you like actually oh
for sure yeah yeah yeah
wow the price of being cool
is very cool thing this is a favor
like you just think i mean to smile and
have that i think is i don't think i
could pull that off but it looks cool i
do want to get a grill though i think i
need it i can't do nothing step into
that why my t2b okay so no grill but we
can do the pacifier
mouth guard oh yeah that's that's the
signature yeah what was the origin of
that by the way um
you're just being different yeah i just
thought about it one day and it just
stuck yeah and the origin of the hair
switching it up uh that's dennis rodman
really
why dennis rodman because he don't care
yeah so
is that like one of the figures that you
oh for sure yeah okay what about his
personality and like the not caring is
so intriguing to you he doesn't care and
doesn't care if you care so like he just
lives his life like he's the only one
walking on this planet yeah and i love
it
do you feel like you're a person who
doesn't care you think you're a person
who wants to not care uh i want to not
care and so i'm working to get to that
point to where dennis is yeah yes how
close are you
whoo i gotta i gotta i got a little
minute to go yeah what are the things
that you find yourself caring about that
you don't wanna i care about a lot of
people
so like i i care about you know what my
mom or my parents are gonna think or
what my siblings are gonna think when
you know it's my life i shouldn't yeah
and that's probably like hindering you
in a lot of ways too because you're like
split in all these different directions
and like not just the yeah the you wow
dennis rodman i don't think i would have
i just thought you liked changing the
hair no no yeah are there any other
athletes that you you know are wanting
to take things from like former athletes
well i love like kobe
mj uh lebron
i'm a big basketball guy i don't know
why really yeah i watch safeties too uh
yeah i played basketball growing up oh
you said you watched safeties yeah so
edri bob sanders was my two guys growing
up ed is the have you ever met ed i've
never met him i'm not kidding you the
coolest
most suave dude you will ever meet and
always got that hat on right
you'll never
yeah i actually um had to go to the nfl
hall of fame last season um one of our
really close family friends was being
inducted and so you know they all have
the gold jackets
ed coming late everyone dressed up he
got on like his jeans and like a little
oh like a wife
he's just like cool that level of care
exactly you're like i'm gonna be me and
i don't
care about what y'all think and it's
crazy because once you unlock that
you'll probably see the fruits of that
exactly in football too
because i'm trying to think like it what
nfl player right now i feel like does
that like just doesn't care they go out
there
and do their stuff oh odell
yeah i'm so happy for him by the way
like he deserved everyone we were just
talking about this with micah on the on
the show too people too often will judge
like
talent and potential based on a
situation that somebody is in
when all of sports it is like
circumstantial and situational there's
only so much you can do when your
environment is not allowing you to be
what you can be so it's cool that now
he's you know playing for super bowl
when people were counting him out you
know and also shout out to obj senior or
ob senior i guess
because you got him out of there for
real
make sure to still make sure that tate
tells the story right
okay so before we uh go into some of the
fan questions tell me
what is success for you individually
next season if we know this stat line
that you had wasn't enough and you know
you can fight for more
what are we looking for from you next um
i'll win it at the end of the day
because
my first two years we won and you know
my stats were pretty good so just
getting back to winning in seattle i
think red's gonna take care of himself
okay and biggest adjustments you feel
like the seahawks will make um i think
they've made a lot of coaching changes
uh this offseason i have seen that um
you know i'm just waiting to get back up
there just to see you know what those
coaches are gonna do to to change the
culture and you know to change the way
to uh know that we used to play football
with that okay cool well i'll shut up
we'll hear from the app now what
questions we got
um favorite you kind of said favorite
players to watch growing up um yeah
favorite players to watch going i was a
big um devin hester ed reed shawn
merriman
um lt
those are pretty much the ones i would
say i watched a lot
you watching defensive players is like
very interesting to me i mean i hang
around bobby more than anybody yeah
that's my that's my guy yeah honestly
there's different personalities between
people that play defense and people
that's like offense like they're not as
flashy they're cool they just want to
get the job done they're like dogs it's
just it's different absolutely okay cool
good players
what else top five quarterbacks you want
to play with
oh
russ
the leader
the question was top five quarterbacks
in a play with his answer was russ and
everything else is blank
um
can you rank your top five wide
receivers in the league what do you
think
top five wide receivers in the league
see i don't like doing that
see because right now i'm feeling a
certain way tomorrow my list may be
different so for today yeah dang you
really gonna do that all right so today
today top five i got a i got one aid
through
a b c d e a a through e so i'm gonna go
with i look julio was somebody i watched
growing up and i'm a big fan of him so
he always gonna be number one devonta
adams
aj
justin jefferson
cooper cup
um
like that like that okay um who's your
favorite team growing up favorite nfl
team favorite nfl team growing up
chargers fan growing up
really
why
i have no idea like i would i remember
just playing madden with uh favre on the
cover
i would use shawn merriman lt phillip
rivers antonio gates antonio camardi i i
like quinn jammer i was just a fan of
really the charges for some reason yeah
well probably because the the d right
yeah yeah yeah their defense was stacked
they were different than okay nice i
would have not thought that i'm a very
defensive minded player how do you think
that helps you as a receiver i don't
care
i'm looking for content yeah
okay nice
wanna do two more yeah what's your
favorite thing about the seattle culture
they loud they yeah they love football
up there yeah they love the seahawks
they love the storm but whatever sports
they have going on up there they love
um you know the the organization so the
fans are probably the best part of being
about being in seattle nice okay and
last one this is the most important
question what's your second favorite
food with ranch
what's your second favorite food with
ranch great question whoever has that
see we got
this is kind of like a loaded question
second favorite wood ranch so you could
throw pizza in there
with ranch
i had some tenders last night that was
pretty good with some ranch
may have said it over the top
oh no
see i'm a little i love food so you
can't get me to talk about food
i can go for a little minute
um i would say all right so you take a
papa john's
cause they just started no dominos they
just started doing the garlic crust
you take a papa john's piece of sausage
throw a little pepperoni little bacon on
there
get you some ranch
oh my gosh
i've never met like a ranch advocate
before i'm not a ranch
hidden valley i grew up on
oh some fried chicken too wings
wait okay no no fried chicken they're
mine's not the same as wings and ranch
fried chicken is wings
no no it's not the same like are you
talking about just like a drumstick and
you're putting so you talking about the
picture no no okay i'm like we are i
can't let this propaganda get out about
it
no no no just the win okay just the
wings okay so if i go to seattle tell me
the restaurant one restaurant i must
attend uh
aji sushi
okay i got a real good solution it's
like two minutes from my crib so okay so
you're there all the time pop in and out
all the time let's go yeah take it back
to the crib watch you for you yeah do do
well now i wouldn't watch it before i
got to catch up on it but i was watching
power then
power okay i loved power like you know
the original but the spin-offs i'm not
watching
you're watching the spin-offs like the
tariq one i'm already done with all that
really i hear the canon one wasn't that
good but the tariq one was pretty good
yes see i watched season one of tariq
first okay without watching power
so i had to go back and re-watch
everything just to catch up gotcha okay
unless you have to know like one day are
we gonna have like a dk restaurant are
you gonna do one yeah yeah for sure
you're doing it all so we got olympics
we got a restaurant
we got a plus season come i'm gonna ask
you for a grade at the end of next
season we got to go up from from b-minus
yeah you can't get worse and b-minus
unless well i mean you quite literally
can't but
it's a restaurant what would it be wait
tell me your full name again like you're
actually kaylin metcalf dekalin metcalf
okay call it decaylens no that's cute
see i'm out of a step ahead of you oh
you know the name oh yeah
tell me
cheesy goodness where cheese is king and
put it on everything
come on
this is southern oh i love it it's a
southern uh a southern italian
restaurant
wait
the food like
it's southern italian southern italian
so you have your pastas and your italian
dishes but with the southern spin on it
hmm southern italian fusion that guys
just like we all thought
wow so yeah not like southern like not
food from southern italy no no no no no
you take a little bit of mississippi
georgia north carolina south carolina
smackdown italy yeah i mean so what
would that dish look like like a like
some fried chicken with some
alfredo
you can have alfredo and then get you
some fried chicken and take the chicken
out and put it in the or you can have
the fried chicken on top of the bed of
alfredo you know what i think would be
like the best menu though
if you have like a brunch menu for that
oh yeah like that could probably hit
like a cheesecake effect for me yeah
yeah but okay last question as we dive
into this very important issue
so it's going to be
southern food and italian food but it's
called cheesy goodness
why
because you put cheese on everything you
could if you think about it
you could literally put cheese on
everything or have like a cheese dish
for any for breakfast lunch or dinner or
dessert yeah but the name isn't
necessarily indicative of the cuisine
right so it'll throw people off so when
you walk in
i was not expecting this now you gotta
stay
now you gotta stay to find out it's all
mind games
see
yes although one could argue you go to
red lobster because it's pretty clear
what you're gonna get so you know
that's for the red lobsters
the red lobster goers
me i'm for the cheesy goodness goer yeah
and i'm also loving like not only do you
have the name like you have the jingle
like you know the slogan jesus came i've
been thinking about this since i was
like seventh grade
yeah no way
always having the title of cheesy
goodness or knowing it was gonna be
southern italian i mean like picking up
pieces every year but like cheesy
goodness stuck in seventh grade
look at this guys is this like the most
important piece of news
if i find all the cheesy goodness going
up it's gonna be you gotta patent it
you're right
i'm a step behind yeah you really are
check is y'all playing
we need the copyright need the power you
need you gotta this it's about ownership
you know what i'm saying
wow okay you let me buy it let me invest
when everything starts
when everything starts moving i'm
expecting a phone call i bet all right
well cheesy goodness thank you so much
uh for joining this was amazing i feel
like i learned so much about you number
one that you have a lot of boot now yeah
thanks so much dk
[Music]